bears quarterback mitchell trubisky is
having a difficult third season in the
nfl the bears are struggling the offense
is struggling and trubisky is struggling
after sunday's loss to the la chargers
coach matt nagy suggested that trubisky
go back chris and look at the tv copy of
the game so he can get a different
perspective as to how trubisky comes
across his facial expressions his
demeanor and trubisky addressed the
topic at his wednesday press conference
indicating that after watching the tv
copy of the game he wasn't very thrilled
with how he came across here's trubisky
from wednesday
i really wasn't doing much i really
wasn't showing any body language is
mostly just like
a guy who looked super serious and kind
of tense and that's really not me
especially when you're going out in the
field and playing the game you love you
should be out there having fun
which i usually am but i just am not
showing that so i think i can portray
that in different ways to especially
that my teammates can feed off of
okay chris here's the thing yeah i don't
know that this works and i don't know
how normal this is you played
quarterback in the nfl have you had you
ever done that had you ever had it
suggested to anyone is this is this new
or is this something that's gone on for
years that we just never heard about
well i think it's you know i don't think
it's like a a common thing where the
coach goes hey go check out the tv copy
and watch your you know body language no
that doesn't go on but i do think that
you know coaches preach to their
quarterbacks about you know the way your
act your mannerisms you know they
they're you know
what do i want to say in effect
infectious to the team uh what am i
trying to say there
i'm trying to say that the way you act
can filter down to the rest of the team
if you're moping around as the
quarterback well the team's going to
mope so you got to be aware of what
you're uh you're putting out there as
far as just your your aura or the the
perceived way of how you feel during the
game now john gruden always made me
aware of that hey man you got to bring
some juice guys are looking to you you
know you got to stay positive you know
you know don't don't don't get down and
sulk when things are bad and added to
that too not only was i aware you know
of course i grew up in it but you know
when i went when the game was over i
wanted to go home and i wanted to sit on
the couch and watch the highlights and
of course i wanted to watch the
highlights even more if i played a
really good game but i was going to
watch them if i played bad too because i
wanted to look at what i looked like
what my body language and facial
expressions were and if they were
acceptable to me even though i don't
always like you know you i didn't like
to watch myself that way but
i knew those were important things and i
did want to have an awareness about
how
my actions and things like that
where they might be as far as affecting
the rest of the team
recent case in point also bears
quarterback jay cutler when adam gase
was there as the offensive coordinator
in 2015 one of the big challenges was to
get cutler to be sensitive to how he
came across right he'd
pull the chin strap off and have his
head down walking off the field and do
those things that create the perception
and then the reality that there's an
attitude problem there's a demeanor
problem and it does rub off on teammates
and and chris i i i feel weird i've been
praising aaron rodgers so much this year
but he deserves it that monday night
game against the lions yeah all those
shots of his face after guys were
dropping passes right and he managed to
keep that serenity now expression right
and it it's important it's critical and
it worked because the the look he knows
how to work with his players and his
teammates and if you start making faces
and grimacing they're going to know
about it they're going to see it they're
going to feel it and it's going to make
it harder for them to perform the way
they need to that's right they feel it i
mean when when you know the pressure
starts to get on them not only because
of the game and now the coaching staff
but like if you drop a ball and you know
now aaron rodgers is his body language
is mad and he might you know mf you or
say something like that you start to go
gosh now i feel the pressure for him i
don't want to let him down i hope i
don't mess that up that can get into
players heads so it is it's all part of
the quarterback position that's why it
is such an important position not only
because you have the ball in your hands
so much but you know you are the leader
of the team you're the captain of the
ship at least is on the offensive side
of the ball for sure and yes the way you
handle yourself in the huddle meeting
rooms all of those things that's why
these teams do these deep dives into
personalities and everything when it's
coming draft time because they want to
know you know what this guy is like on
an everyday 24-7 basis what's he's like
when the crap hits the fan and what does
he like when things are awesome
uh and all those things go into making a
great quarterback uh and you're right
aaron rodgers i think has turned the
corner there as far as being even a
better leader there uh and trubisky you
know a lot of this is set up by of
course the bears fans and i do look at
matt nagy being a little responsible
with this too because i don't think he
always gave him the greatest public
votes of confidence when he was coming
in the door in chicago so that's why
he's tense man the fans are on me we're
not winning you know and he probably
feels that his coach is not maybe
totally a back behind him all the time
and uh he's probably not as loose as
he'd like to be on the field
you know fascinating behind the scenes
issues that can play out in chicago
after this season what do they do about
mitchell trubisky do they pick up the
fifth year option on his contract in may
as of this point i'd say they probably
don't does ryan pace feel compelled to
double down with trubisky because pace
is the guy who traded up to take him
when patrick mahomes and deshaun watson
were still on the board do they keep
going and going and going with trubisky
to justify
taking trubisky where they did in the
first place or do they move on all
together
fascinating decisions that await the
chicago bears unless they can turn it
around they're still only three and four
right right right so they still have a
chance yes but based on what we've seen
in recent weeks it doesn't look like
it's gonna work out for the bear
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports